[Music]
and gamer rehab news rehabilitation for
a gamer by I ate my booger Oh salty a
teenager addicted to video games goes
through treatment in the wilderness in
the wilderness in China
is this a program or it's like self
recovery a program well I want to go to
this humble gram in general of the
wilderness yeah I write songs in a
resonator just normal I don't know what
what like the wilderness makes me feel
so good and I didn't know that as a kid
like like I just we went camping a lot
we went in there did fishing all that
stuff and um I didn't really associate
my happiness and just me feeling good
like with the wilderness and nature and
in all that [ __ ] I don't know I I didn't
think that that was the reason why [ __ ]
oh sure you did something to me recently
that I have gotten addicted to [ __ ]
primitive technology guy [ __ ] that guy
because because of him I cannot stop
watching wilderness survival [ __ ] yeah
constantly [ __ ] dope right like it's
a minute I'm trying to figure out how
many different ways I can start a fire
without a liner yeah like you know like
how many different types of tinder like
birds all this other [ __ ] is so [ __ ]
fascinating I know it's like when we go
into the forest right we lost the
freaking skill and ability to go I could
make a [ __ ] house out of everything
I'll need tools I'll build the tools
from everything that I see I really want
to make a fire doing the the plough
technique where you just have to stick
in the groove and you yeah and then you
get that bit it's so [ __ ] like how
that's among guy did with a freaking
eucalyptus tree yeah branches I want to
do that I want to do it without using
the foot the Flintstone you know I mean
so just the to stick with just friction
alone and that's pretty amazing and it's
this guy who actually teaches people how
to do it with like a ziploc bag
any liquid and used as a magnifying up I
am it's pretty [ __ ] so none you do it
with the battery and some like some like
[ __ ] gum wrapper and shared with like
steel wool it's [ __ ] dope man
and for some reason it's so calming to
like watching it it's like what we also
camping we're not allowed to use you get
a fire going by normal means react one
of us has to do it I think it's going to
take some practice before we commit to
something if we can't sadly we can't eat
until somebody does it though I'll be
the plan B and I'll have a propane take
whatever we need I give up come on over
here I'll be in the car no sign by me
and you will figure it out no one's on
your team are you really starving for
like a week that's that's the reality of
it though is it's hard to find food in
the wild yeah so we'll just get skinny
okay that's a great weight loss program
horrible parasites and get skinny
horrible tapeworm diet whoo
so this team his name is Josh he's 14
years old he is part of a 2020 uh 20
tweets you know the 23 oh but thanks
night late night guys I'm going to show
you guys this 2020 clip of Josh and his
parents dealing with his gaming
addiction and his wilderness program I
love the wilderness awesome and stop
playing video games with all the gravity
of Josh's life sleeping in till 11 12 ok
and until like 1:00 2:00 in the morning
his parents bastard Christina say he's
up playing 60 hours a week traffic into
the wee hours of the morning you know we
are average three o'clock and I told you
to get off at 1:00
ah I don't understand because when we
did take it away there was a lot of
problems
it is a cool behavior Alan come on come
on and on computer even locked the
router out in the car
Josh responds by lashing out and then
eventually dropping out of school
there's just a lot of anger lots of
anger emotional outbursts yeah sounds
completely out of control
yeah Josh's parents are so desperate to
help their son they decide to send him
to a Utah wilderness program called
unplugged without back therapeutic
expeditions the program waived
Josh's fee to bring attention to
obsessive Green youth here just a few
other boys will camp for weeks with no
running water electricity or computer
screens I'm Elizabeth it's very nice to
meet you I check in on Josh more than
seven weeks into the program service are
teaching self reliance on long hikes and
through roughing it all hoping to give
the boys insight into the compulsions
that brought them here I'm noticing my
it was real bad the next day his parents
come to visit after the longest and most
difficult separation of his young life
hey Josh how are you good good to see
you oh my god you're getting bigger
yes a family critical dad I know there's
some exchangers it sound like getting
dogs at a dog park yeah hey Toby how are
ya yep right here the boy who could
barely bring himself to put a few words
together is now reflective I got home I
didn't really notice that really
destroying me mentally and you just say
whatever the [ __ ] you tank if you could
go back and play leave Oh suck a dick
man who's the really bad school for a
month
just take the game well in school for a
month did you catch it behind for now
there's more work to do in the desert I
hope I smell the pine cones dude if you
can rewind like that he tattoos that you
would never ever seven weeks like a
[ __ ] tiny print realism you know what
I don't like about like this approach is
that extreme no it's kind of like it's
like they're making it the kids problem
it's not it's not a our problem
yeah like kids are escaping into video
games and doing all this stuff because
whatever is going on in the house
marital problems or whatever problems at
school they're escaping and of course
this program is going to work they're
around other you know guys that they can
be friends with their mind is constantly
occupied by new things new stimulus new
challenges it's fun or you know it's
challenging but then once they get out
of it they're back into their regular
life again they're going to escape back
to the game yeah for me I feel like what
you've gone through it's not like this
crazy-ass addiction I think it's a
normal teen behavior I did that [ __ ]
well the update I was that when he got
back home uh you know they got rid of
his computer stand up selling it I
believe he was a pile of sticks in his
bedroom I think the difference between
like what you're talking about he just
didn't go to school didn't do anything
yeah I see so he missed a whole month
yeah I mean like he just didn't do
anything at all that's when it's a
problem like that's when it becomes an
addiction when it affects your regular
life but even for me when I didn't play
a lot of games that I did play games I
still got my [ __ ] done though so you
couldn't say [ __ ] you know to me shower
really he wasn't showering you know yeah
so I still paying I still did my [ __ ] I
still had to do my chores stuff friends
no socialize exactly I think for him he
was just glued into the game and wasn't
doing just [ __ ] how do you think you
would handle your kids with technology
I'd be like exactly with them doing a
[ __ ] if a new game came out that I
really could have already moved away
we'll be playing on Bill I hold up I got
to do a jackoff break boom
whack off come back play that was my
[ __ ] teen teen years I did that [ __ ]
even but I had a wreck
life - so I feel like this is normal I
think it's normal if there's the regular
life - like you go outside and you play
like basketball with your friends or
some view with your friends walk at
night and then you you still hang out
with your friends online
yeah like playing games and [ __ ] yeah
well because the only game that I was
really addicted to with Petra net and I
still play that at all 4:00 a.m. in the
morning either one of a hella good well
there's a [ __ ] good at that game
it's like Tetris but you're battling
people and there's all these little
bombs and like nukes faces or Center
each other to play in an office yeah
well if you only gain that I really got
addicted to not play until 4:00 a.m. but
I still good normal [ __ ] I still play
drums later and so let's go eat my
friend's dog ain't bangs colleges normal
[ __ ] you're so full of electives I don't
know man like I think like things are
cool I guess in my kid get centaurs is
fine I just don't I think if I have a
kid I would like try to have him live a
life without being attached to a thing
so much you understand that this is cool
I mean obviously I don't know I don't
have a kid yet I don't know how much I
could control it but I would do my best
to because my parents did that too you
know I mean they allowed us to play
games but they controlled in a way where
I didn't have to like it so much you
know like I joined it but i didn't i
didn't like wrap my whole life around it
like i wasn't too fond oh you know we
all in soccer I did all of a sudden
[ __ ] you know I like this wilderness
program though I just do it for fun like
no one has to force me to go there like
I want to go there stop missing out on
all of the JK news uploads don't forget
to subscribe so you know when the videos
are coming up and for the last video
click over here
[Music]